the beldum commonly known as the other
mother was an evil entity that existed
as early as the 1700s it is not known
when the other father came into
existence but one line in the book
suggests that it was long before the
beldum created the illusion of the other
world
he tells coraline there isn't anywhere
but here this is all she made
the house the grounds and the people in
the house she made it
and she waited this suggests that the
other father was around to see the
creation of the house the rats
the dog bat things and the other
misspink enforceable and in the movie
the other wivey who is not in the book
but unlike any of those creatures the
other father demonstrates a will of its
own to fight back against the influence
of the beldum to explore the true nature
of the mysterious being behind the
facade of the other father stick around
to the end of this video
the other world is the creepy harrowing
alternate realm adjacent to coraline's
home it was created by the beldum
looking to feast on the souls of
whatever children it can lure into its
domain
everything it created was a twisted copy
of something from horrorline's world
except for the other father who seems to
have existed long before coraline's real
father was in the picture
welcome to horror history i'm going to
explore the entire history of the other
father including the dark truth only
seen in the book but before i do i've
gotta really really quickly mention this
episode sponsor
raycon what else can i say that i
haven't already said about the everyday
e25 earbuds so many of you have already
voiced your satisfaction after picking
up your pair using my link for 15
off you'll get six hours of play time
seamless bluetooth powering more bass a
more compact design that gives you a
nice noise isolating fit just ask some
of your favorite celebrities
michael myers the invisible man llama
arts i'm out of time but get yours by
raycon.com slash these world link in the
description fifteen percent off by recon
dot com
sheezy's world forever
how did the other father get to the
belgium's world based on the information
available in the book there are two
possibilities
one is that it was actually the initial
inhabitant it was there before the
beldum discovered the realm and made it
into her lair
killing whatever other creatures dwelled
there and keeping this one around only
to do her bidding the other father is
described as a huge white swollen
monster with a vague face like pale clay
it had something that resembled the nose
and the mouth does not appear when
closed but opens up with sticky pale
strands when open
the skin is described similar to warm
bread dough and when coraline meets it
it has black button eyes but those were
probably not originally part of its
anatomy likely added by the other mother
as a sign that she had taken its soul
this leads me to the second possibility
about the other father's origins
it may have been one of the previous
victims of the belden when coraline
meets the ghost children their souls
have been separated from their bodies
and they're no longer able to remember
details about their true selves what if
after the belgium begins feasting on the
souls the bodies associated with them
lose their detail and lose what makes
them them
there are three ghost children whose
souls have been taken two girls and one
boy the other mother has three
accomplices two female and one male
remember yb isn't in the book and the
man upstairs is actually just a pack of
rats in human clothing
so the other father may have originally
been the body of the young ghost boy
that was sucked of its individuality by
the beldum and then reformed and
reconfigured to look like coraline's
father the idea is backed up when
coraline has this realization
these things even the thing in the
cellar were illusions things made by the
other mother in a ghastly parody of real
people and real things on the other end
of the corridor
she could not truly make anything
decided coraline she could only twist
and copy and distort things that already
existed
when the jones family moved to the house
the belden wanted to turn the other
world into an ideal paradise for
coraline in order to trick her into
staying and so
formed herself and her prisoners into
ideal versions of the people in
coralline's life the real mr jones not
the one from the counting crow song but
coraline's dad
makes recipes that are too complex for
coraline's simple taste buds but the
chad other father makes her delicious
midnight snacks and hot chocolates
coraline first meets her other father
after arriving in the other world when
her other mother tells her to go fetch
him for lunch
she finds him in his study with big
black shiny buttons for eyes he claims
that he's starving and that they've been
waiting for her for a long time
we know that the beldum doesn't thrive
on real food but rather feasts on
children's souls so it's possible that
she made the other father say this line
about being hungry just to add
authenticity to the illusion
in this analysis i'm looking at the
character from the book not the movie
but the book doesn't tell us whether or
not the other father actually eats the
food in the movie he does whereas the
other mother does not she only eats
insects and souls
she just loves something to eat eat
that's ridiculous another possibility is
that the beldum is unable to suppress
her subconscious desires from
manifesting in the other father while
she's controlling him
again i'm hesitant to bring this up
because it's only in the movie not the
book but when he sings the song for
coraline he's being controlled by these
hands created by the other mother
russia this piano plays me and the
lyrics of the song call her a peach a
doll
and cute as a button
she's a peach
calling her a doll and a button shows
the beldum's desire to take her soul and
sew buttons over her eyes and calling
her a peach shows that the beldum sees
her as a tasty snack hmm
who's starving raise your hand
again it's not his hands that rise it's
the beldum's hands controlling him but
going back to the book now the other
father remains mostly passive in the
coming scenes he helps the other mother
clean up for lunch and when coraline
goes outside to explore he tells her
they'll be waiting for her to come back
with smiles and waves when she gets back
he is the one to suggest that if she
likes it in their world she can stay
forever by letting them sew the buttons
over her eyes
he tries to assure her that it won't
hurt which only makes her think that it
definitely will
coraline goes back to her own world to
discover her real parents have gone
missing so eventually she has to return
to the beldum's world to try to win them
back but when she does she notices some
strange new behavior coming
from her other father
when coraline returns to the alternate
world she is greeted by her other mother
but her other father is just strangely
sitting in a chair in the hallway before
he stands up to greet her
the other mother at least does stuff she
has things of her own to tend to but the
other father is almost like an item
just waiting to be used by her but it
seems that her ability to manipulate him
is dictated by some kind of energy
because when coraline first arrives
everything is set up perfectly to make
him almost indistinguishable from her
real thought but as she grows more and
more hungry the cracks in his facade are
starting to show and she's not able to
have full control over him all of the
time
when coldline asks why they don't have
their own key for the door between the
two worlds he blurts out an answer there
is only one key
only one door said the other father hush
said the other mother you must not
bother our darling coraline's head with
such trivialities
this is the first time he says something
out of line meaning that her control
over him could be slipping he gets even
weirder the next morning when coraline
goes into his study looking for the
other mother he sat at his desk
not actually doing anything not even
pretending to be doing anything she also
notices that his face looks more vague
describing it as looking like a bread
dough that has begun to rise
he tells her that the other mother is
outside fixing the doors so she tries to
engage him in conversation
instead of the usual friendly attitude
he puts on he tells her that he's not
allowed to talk to her but he'll
continue to be hospitable once the other
mother is back but when coraline tells
him that she's gonna go exploring he
accidentally slips up and tells her
there's no point because the beldum
didn't create anything further than the
eye can see
he looked embarrassed and he put one
finger to his lips again as if he had
just said too much
he is the only character to demonstrate
the free will to say what
he wants but the other mother punishes
him for exercising this ability by
locking him away in the cellar
underneath the abandoned flat he also
continues to lose whatever resemblance
he has left to coraline's real father
and by the time coraline finds him down
there he's swelled out into this
monstrous form with only his voice
somewhat resembling that of the original
other father and his two black button
eyes signifying he's still under control
of the beldum she would use that control
as a trap for coraline
at this point the creature has had
enough and is trying to fight back
against the other mother coraline
figures out that he's been locked away
as punishment for his loose lips earlier
and the creature nods to confirm
he also tries to warn her run child
leave this place
she wants me to hurt you to keep you
here forever
so you
the movie is a little bit different in
the movie there's no cellar scene and
the other father seems to have been
crafted using a pumpkin from the garden
but as time goes on he loses his
father-like qualities and becomes more
halloweeny but the way he tries to fight
the beldum's control is very similar
roll sorry
[Music]
so sorry mother
in the book when the other mother tries
to make attack her coraline encourages
it to be brave which is interesting
because from the very beginning the
other mother had been trying to make
this thing into an ideal version of
coraline's dad
however it seems the one thing that she
didn't teach it was braver and
coraline's real dad was the one to teach
coraline the concept of bravery after
this one incident where they
accidentally walked into a swarm of
wasps and he had to stay back and let
them sting him in order for her to get
away
i guess the message here is that you can
dress someone up and make them appear a
certain way but you can't create bravery
artificially that's something you must
learn from experience
however the monster was not able to hold
off to beldum any longer it moved
between her and the steps cutting off
her exit and it gradually grew in size
its voice becoming less and less human
before finally it lunged across the room
towards her after seeing the monster
looking lost after one of the button
eyes had fallen off earlier she ripped
off the second eye causing it to roar in
pain and charge the area that it had
last seen her standing but
it was too slow its only option was to
go quiet
and listen it could hear her tiptoeing
up the steps and it took off after her
but she was too quick and it crashed
against the trapdoor above as she closed
it
perhaps being forever trapped and
forgotten never again do we see the
horror that temporarily masqueraded as
the other father leaving both its
origins and its fates a mystery
that i can only speculate on as i have
in this video but if not for the
creature's timely rush of courage our
hero may have never been warned of the
beldum's nasty deceptions and likely
would have been the next victim to be
used and abused by the other mother
click the video on the left for my
complete playlist of coraline character
histories including coraline
the beldum and yb and if you love horror
make sure you subscribe to cz's world
for new horrors
every week ring the death bell for
notifications and i'll see you in the
next one
assuming we stay inside